okay we have to get back to the action
this rook still finds itself attacked
but white just flicked in a check
nothing much has changed the black
king's stepping forward and
oh my god vidi i think he's panicking
because ten seconds and he's facing
checkmating ideas black is threatening
the same idea with his rook and uh i
don't think there's any way out now for
vidic four seconds seconds three seconds
okay and he's moved his bishop but uh
okay so there's
now there's a threat of pawn takes work
but and he's attacking the square but
you can solve both of those problems
with one move bring the black rook
across you're about to overwhelm this
pawn and i think black's about to get to
the white king quicker than white can
get to the black king
this looks like game over almost
naraditsky if he finds this move bring
his rook across to defend and attack at
the same time yeah he should be winning
but
he's an artist he's maybe looking for an
even flashier continuation
no you can be dull at times you can dare
to be that and uh just go for the most
ruthless uh move and rook moving he's
gesturing let's go back to the players
oh three seconds two seconds okay and
he's given a check
no but this is he can just take the rook
he's gone for the draw he's giving up
his rook but now after pawn takes rook
we'll see a bit of a yo-yo the knight
will check but now the king can run
towards the center and we will see a
check forever and a draw the position
will repeat itself let's go back to the
players for these final few seconds
there's just no way out for the white
king but black is a rook down so black
can't play on either for the win
and
ski a draw
a draw a really exciting draw but a
missed chance for him naredix